[Musique]
le soutien à la parentalité et le suivi
médical des jeunes enfants sont assurées
au sein des centres de protection
maternelle et infantile
une quarantaine de ces structures se
répartit sur l'ensemble du territoire à
la réunion les pmi conseille et
accompagne les parents à la conception
et au cours des six premières années de
l'enfant et centres de pmi du conseil
départemental ont un dispositif qui
s'appelle la fenêtre des 1000 premiers
jours il s'agit d'accompagner les
parents futurs parents et jeunes parents
depuis la grossesse et sur les deux
premières années de l'enfant de façon
renforcée afin de pouvoir repérer des
signes d' alerte d'avoir une vigilance
particulière pour les situations de
précarité ou d'isolement de familles
monoparentales également de pouvoir les
accompagner avec un accès aux soins
gratuits des ateliers collectifs de
soutien à la parentalité puis quand on
repère une situation de plus grande
fragilité ou vulnérabilité ont fait une
orientation vers les services sociaux du
département pour que les familles soit
accompagné de façon globale sur
l'ensemble de leur parcours les centres
de protection maternelle et infantile
sont constitués d' équipe
pluridisciplinaire médecins sages femmes
infirmières puéricultrices auxiliaires
de puériculture éducatrices de jeunes
enfants tout ce personnel travaille à
l'épanouissement et au bien-être des
enfants au sein de leur milieu familial
à la fois dans les centres mais
également lors de visites à domicile
ici dans cet atelier les jeunes mamans
profitent des consultations post natale
pour échanger et disposer de conseils
ça permet de consolider des liens avec
un bébé et puis c'est un moment de
douceur c'est un moment de partage aussi
avec les autres mamans viennent donne
beaucoup de conseils sont à des petites
questions des interrogations par rapport
à mai rivé sur peu importe le sujet que
ce soit sur l'alimentation sur le sommet
sur toutes sortes de choses elle est là
vraiment pour nous apporter beaucoup de
choses
proposer un suivi médical gratuits
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
sans critères ni conditions d'accès s'y
assurer l'égalité des chances et
garantir le droit à la santé des enfants
les centres de protection maternelle et
infantile sont les premiers piliers de
l'action médico social en faveur de
l'enfance porté par le département au
plus près des familles
[Musique]